[Music]
when mexico sends its people they're not
sending their best
do immigrants bring with them the worst
attributes of the countries they left
behind
that fear motivates populist
nationalists and some free market
economists
such as harvard's george borjas
britain's paul collier
and george mason's garrett jones who
speculate that
mass immigration from countries with
illiberal traditions will
undermine western culture in their new
book
wretched refuse the political economy of
immigration and institutions
the cato institute's alex nerosta and
texas tech university economist benjamin
powell took an exhaustive look at the
data
and found that destination countries not
only benefit
economically from immigration but that
key markers of liberal democracy
such as support for the rule of law
limited government and private property
rights
improve when newcomers arrive on mass
when
cubans leave cuba and move to south
florida they're not cubans who want to
recreate cuban socialism
they're the most anti-socialist voting
bloc in the united states
similarly but to a lesser extent
californians who are fleeing
gavin newsom's lockdown state there and
moving to texas
are not the type of people who want to
recreate california in texas
powell points to the example of israel
in the 1990s which took in a
massive number of refugees from the
former soviet union
a massive flood of people coming from a
country with a 70-year history of no
rule of law
no economic freedoms pile into israel
with immediate voting rights because of
the law of return
it increased the population of israel by
about 20 percent in that decade
confidence in property rights didn't go
down
it went up economic freedoms across the
board except size of government but that
recovered overall
israel went something from like 90th in
the world in economic freedom to 45th
during a period of massive immigration
from a communist country
narasta stresses that the u.s created
its largest social
welfare programs such as social security
and medicare at times when
immigration flows were at historic lows
immigrants coming in make native born
people in the u.s
less likely to support bigger government
to support welfare states because they
don't want to give these benefits to
foreigners who are coming in
despite or perhaps because of donald
trump's anti-immigration animus
positive views of the contribution of
newcomers are at record highs
public opinion eventually affects policy
and one interpretation i think of the
donald trump era
is it's sort of like the temper tantrum
before everything changes sort of in the
same way than the mid-1960s george
wallace and others sort of having their
large nationwide temper tantrum
against the end of segregation and if
you were just looking at what political
candidates were saying you'd say wow
this segregation stuff is really on the
upswing
in the mid to late 1960s but it was
really the opposite it's sort of like
the death rattle of it
what you see amongst republicans amongst
independents amongst democrats
is either they like immigration as much
as they always have or the
favorabilities are going
through the roof narasta says that
translating public opinion into
pro-immigration policy
is a slow and sloppy process he was an
outspoken critic of the relatively
restrictive policies of george w bush
and barack obama
along with those of donald trump but he
and powell are
optimistic that policy will eventually
catch up to public opinion
we can point back to our italian irish
welsh persian ancestors who came here
and face sort of the same criticism that
immigrants are facing today whether it's
about institutions like our book is
about
or whether it's about economics or
anything else and these
fears in the past turned out to be
unfounded and we can make that argument
again and again in the u.s